IT'S NOW TIME TO PLAY "SELFIE
ESTEEM: GYM EDITION."
I MEAN, WHY EVEN GO TO THE GYM
IF YOU DON'T POST A SELFIE TO
SHOW EVERYONE YOU GO TO THE GYM?
I'VE GOT TO BE HONEST, I
ACTUALLY DID THAT ONCE.
( LAUGHTER )
I'M A HYPOCRITICAL DOUCHEBAG.
COMEDIANS I'M GOING TO SHOW YOU
SOME SELF-ABSORBED FIT-PICS, AND
FOR 250 POINTS, YOU GIVE ME
THEIR INNER MONOLOGUE.
FIRST UP, THIS HUMAN CHUNK OF
BEEF JERKY.
>> THAT RADIOACTIVE GAY GUY IN
THE SHOWER HAS GIVEN ME STRANGE
POWERS.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
POINTS.
KURT.
>> I'M A VEINY BAG OF WALNUTS.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
( APPLAUSE )
>> I'M LIKE A STEROID
BOBBLEHEAD.
NEXT ONE: THIS SPREAD-EAGLED
GYM RAT IN SEXY LEGGINGS.
>> YOU WERE ALL OVER THAT ONE,
YOU'RE LIKE, I'M IN!
IG--
TCH.>> IT'S KEGEL EXERCISES LIKE
THIS THAT ENABLE ME TO CRUSH A
MAN!
>> CHRIS: POINTS, YOU GOTTA DO
THEM.
>> THAT'S A USEFUL SKILL.
BY THE WAY, BRO, YOU DON'T HAVE
TO HASH TAG EVERY ( BLEEP )
WORD.
HASHTAG JIM SELFIE, HASH TAG
CALVES, HASH TAG GYM RAT, HASH
TAG GYM MODE, HASH TAG FIT
FREAK, HASH TAG MOTIVATED, HASH
TAG FOCUS, HASH TAG DRIVEN, HASH
TAG, YOU SHOULD NOT BE ON
INSTAGRAM.
YOU HAVE TO HASH TAG EVERY
( BLEEP ) WORD.
( APPLAUSE )
HASHTAG MY BROTHERS DON'T CALL
ME ANYMORE FOR SOME REASON.
( LAUGHTER )
NEXT ONE, THIS BARB ARE A LEG
FOR AN ARM.
YES, JIM?
>> COME HERE, BOY.
MOMMA HAS SOME PEANUT BUTTER FOR
YOU.
( APPLAUSE )
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
JOHN.
>> HI, DO YOU HAVE A MOMENT TO
TALK ABOUT JOSEPH SMITH AND THE
CHURCH OF JESUS CHRIST OF LATTER
DAY SAINTS.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.